bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors vous avez
décidé de déposer un recours en
annulation du décret de reconnaissance
en maladie professionnelle du coc vide
19 explications pourquoi bien en fait ce
cette reconnaissance en maladie
professionnelle n'est pas vraiment une
reconnaissance en maladie
professionnelle on a pris seulement en
fait les soignants et assimilés d'une
part et d'autre part on a restreint même
pour eux
en fait on ne prend pas c'est pas une
indemnisation ou une reconnaissance en
maladie professionnelle du coc vide
c'est de certaines atteintes graves et
uniquement les atteintes respiratoires
donc pas du tout les atteintes
neurologiques ni cardiaque et uniquement
celles qui ont été traités par
assistance respiratoire
donc on est sur quelque chose d'infimes
on est peut-être sur 100 personnes peut
être 200 personnes donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui n'a aucun rapport avec
l'ensemble du problème de
l'indemnisation des victimes du duc au
vide alors ce décret vous estimez que
c'est un peu de la poudre aux yeux
oui c'est vraiment de la deûle à de la
poudre aux yeux
cc c'est clairement quelque chose l'idée
derrière c'est qu'on veut pas assumer
des responsabilités
donc en fait on limite complètement les
choses à quelque chose où l'on dit pas
qu'il ya delà de la responsabilité du
gouvernement derrière donc c'est c'est
là le problème
alors bon on fait un recours pour pour
l'annuler je pense que le décret est
manifestement illégal parce que ce qu'on
indemnise n'est pas une maladie
normalement quand on fait un tableau de
maladies professionnelles dans la
législation française
on désigne quelque chose qui est une
maladie ici on ne désigne pas une
maladie ce qu'on désigne c'est une
attaque particulière de cette maladie à
savoir
une atteinte respiratoire et qui plus
est qui a été traitée d'une certaine
façon
enfin c'est pas du tout le système des
maladies professionnelles
donc il ya un certain nombre d'arguments
juridiques pour s'opposer à ceux à ce
décret et c'est ce qu'on fait on dépose
aujourd'hui un recours devant le conseil
d'état pour annuler ce décret vous
estimez donc l'état est responsable de
quelle manière at il été responsable
dans cette crise sanitaire
il est responsable de multiples manières
c'est à dire qu'on avait au départ
toutes les données et au mois de février
ils ont pas pas au départ pas au mois de
janvier bien évidemment mais à partir du
15 février du 20 février on avait toutes
les données sur le sujet pour pouvoir
agir on savait ce qu'il aurait fallu
faire les mesures de prévention sont
bien connues elles sont appliquées dans
les pays du sud est asiatique sous
divers ce régime qui ne sont pas tous
autoritaire et on peut parfaitement
maîtrisé une épidémie avec les mesures
absolument classique qui sont le port du
masque le test des malades l'isolément
des personnes contaminées la recherche
des contacts
un certain nombre de limitations dans
les rassemblements et en particulier les
rassemblements privé c'est ça qui a
manqué cet été notamment et mais tout ça
n'a pas été fait rien n'a été fait on a
même recommandé de ne pas porter le
masque ça s'éteint c'est un aspect c'est
à dire que on pouvait parfaitement évité
toutes ces victimes on ne l'a pas fait
on a choisi de ne pas le faire parce
qu'on était sur une sur une espèce
d'idéologie de libre circulation qui
impliquait la libre circulation du virus
est ensuite il ya eu 1 une autre
dimension qui a été peut-être encore
plus plus difficile à vivre pour les
victimes et pour les familles pour les
familles des personnes décédées
c'est la façon dont les soins ont été
organisées ou plus exactement pas
organiser c'est à dire que
beaucoup de gens n'ont pas eu le droit
aux soins hospitaliers auxquels il
aurait dû avoir normalement droit et en
particulier sur des critères d'âge c'est
à dire que on disait il est trop vieux
donc il ne sera pas hospitalisés et tout
ça c'est des responsabilités qui sont
des responsabilités énormes
il y à des procédures judiciaires qui
sont lancés et qui sont en cours des
procédures pénales on en verra le
résultat nous avons nous lancer une
procédure y compris une procédure
criminelle pour délaissement des
personnes c'est justement qu'on a refusé
de soigner qu'on a laissé nourrir soit à
domicile soit dans l'est soit dans les
ehpad et puis ce qu'il ya c'est que de
toute façon les personnes qui sont
malades et qu'ils le sont longtemps
qu'ils ont des ses cales parce qu'il ya
des personnes qui ont des séquelles et
pas seulement des séquelles
respiratoires eh bien il faut les
indemniser et donc nous ce qu'on demande
c'est un fonds d'indemnisation pour
toutes les victimes et y compris bien
sûr pour les familles de victimes
décédées
justement la création se font des
garanties revend ce fonds pour toutes
ces victimes du coronavirus sans les ouf
enfin pour le moment le gouvernement
refuse bien évidemment c'est pour ça
qu'il fait un semblant d'indemnisation
qui est vraiment cesser ses achats
je veux pas le dire pour les médecins
mais c'est quand même presque ridicule
quoi d'arriver à ce titre
d'indemnisation extrêmement ciblées
alors que d'autres personnes ont été
plus exposés mais ne seront pas
indemnisés d'autres ont des séquelles
plus importante et ne seront pas
indemnisés non plus enfin c'est vraiment
du bricolage et qui est encore une fois
uniquement destinée à ne pas reconnaître
la responsabilité de l'état parce que
créer un fonds d'indemnisation c'est
reconnaître une forme de responsabilité
dans cette catastrophe
en fait on veut pas parler des victimes
et d'ailleurs on parle pas de victimes
le gouvernement j'amène utilise le mot
victime on utilise on ne veut surtout
pas voir des victimes ni d'ailleurs des
associations de victimes on peut écrire
autant qu'on veut en tant qu'association
de victimes au gouvernement on n'a
jamais de réponse
c'est la première fois que je vois ça je
m'occupe beaucoup d'aidé des victimes
depuis 25 ans et c'est la première fois
où je vois quelque chose comme ça c'est
une négation de la notion de
deux victimes merci beaucoup d'avoir été
en direct avec nous sur rt france
monsieur parigot je rappelle que vous
êtes président du collectif corona
victimes merci